hank halter suivent une émission trop
racoleuse il hier soir en 2ème partie de
soirée sur m6 y avait à nouveau numéro
d' enquête exclusive et sur les forces
de réponse immédiate la haye ferry
la nouvelle unité de police anti-drogue
comme très souvent il a été question de
drogue dans cette émission c'est une
semaine sur deux ils ont prononcé le mot
drogue ou un autre synonyme 92 fois
pendant le reportage
regardez bonsoir et bienvenue dans
quêtes exclusives en france la drogue
continue de faire des ravages les
réseaux de drogue plaque tournante de la
drogue aurait un stock de drogue de la
drogue du cannabis cannabis cannabis
cannabis cannabis cannabis cocaïne
héroïne à un demi kilo d'héroïne
l'hérault la coque drogue drogue drogue
drogue drogue passé voilà qu'au début
donc c'était bon sens cas dexia aussi
tombé sur le champion du monde des
dealers il a proposé de la drogue
un policier le mec il est direct m'a dit
est ce que tu vois là ça va je vais
regarder hier en cas d'ex ou du non mais
j'ai vu que le premier ministre a parlé
de d'imaginer en tout cas de légaliser
pour bientôt la drogue de glace à
touches cannabis thérapeutique 1er un
petit merci à la gauche de la drogue
voilà c'est ça va vous n'avez rappeuse
jamais touché en fumé un joint autres
comme ça jamais thérapeutique
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
regardez regardez depuis la fenêtre le
major voit son adjoint fred se faire
accoster par un homme en bleu sur le
parking sous les yeux de choc
fred joue le jeu d'un toxicomane qui va
acheter sa dose il s'approche du dealer
est soudain pris de court le major
dévale les escaliers pour prêter main
forte à son coéquipier vous êtes regard
des policiers
c'est vraiment un abruti fait soi même
pu faire la part des choses entre un
policier et un toxicomane
apparemment on n'a pas non plus des
faciès de brouiller il était quoi les
clignotements des bords du rhin à kehl
qui disent qu'en pensez vous trop
racoleur ça ah oui non c'est le sait où
on en est aujourd'hui
je pense que là ils font leur travail
correctement par rapport aux lois comme
elles sont prévues mais d'ici peu de
temps ça devrait changer
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
allez ça